you cannot watch movies or television
these days without seeing stories about
robots or other machines taking over the
world that's science fiction at least so
far other people have serious real-world
concerns about artificial intelligence
tonight correspondent Gillian Turner
shows us the debate about the future of
this technology the world is becoming a
computer computing is getting embedded
in every person place and thing
artificial intelligence known as AI as
the emerging technology experts believe
will shape the future of human existence
for the first time in history scientists
are predicting innovation won't always
be the sole domain of human beings
devices spurred by AI are already widely
available and new uses are discovered on
a weekly basis the latest development
comes from Google and allows people
smartphones to make appointments on
their behalf using a shockingly
realistic sounding digital voice do you
have anything between 10 a.m. and 12
p.m. we have a 10 o'clock 10:00 a.m. is
fine AI advances like these are coming
so fast and furious they've got the
attention of President Trump who's
launching a new push to ensure companies
use the technology responsibly and
protect American consumers this
afternoon the White House Office of
Science and Technology Policy hosted its
first-ever summit on AI bringing
together tech giants including Amazon
Facebook Google Intel and 34 other major
US companies it focused on a eyes roll
in five key US sectors food and
agriculture energy and manufacturing
financial services health care and
transportation and logistics to date the
commercial use of AI remains larger than
regulated though lawmakers are waking up
to concerns about privacy the arms race
to produce individual predictive results
is only increasing with Smart Assistance
bike Alexa and Siri in your pocket and
listening at home for your next command
high tech leaders have also begun to
pursue federal dollars for advancing
their innovations meaning that Congress
will have an increasingly large role to
play in the development of AI going
forward
but it's not just private industry
that's interested in using more AI and
its products the US military is also
developing new technology like these
patrol robots who serve as the eyes and
ears for US troops on the ground
national security experts are ringing
alarm bells about the threat of AI
cyberattacks digital tools or enemies
can use to attack us cyber systems they
say American development of AI is now an
urgent national security priority Brett
this is a story we'll follow a lot
Jillian thank you